guys congratulations on another really
enjoyable run as the Warrens and I'm
curious you guys actually got to play
like the Warrens largely having an
enjoyable time how is it returning to
these characters and not having to like
go to the depths of despair right he's
refreshing yeah it was nice to bring
something completely different totally
to it and to write that responsibility
was off our shoulders what we usually do
in the conjuring films was it
necessarily demanded of us in this job
of the opening was well especially
coming off of the heels of what Lauren
was going through in the conduits where
do we go when the baby-sitters club
start like got another case where did we
really you don't think you were taking
me to the Pacific confirmed oh wow you
guys were playing totally different
realities just stick in the mud I was
going to work just a workhorse what I do
is make me work how's it bringing your
workhorse vibe yes torturing her with a
new a new filmmaker at the home you've
got to play these characters for a whole
new yeah that was a much different
experience and now we're going through
it Eva honestly I always get a little
skeptical yeah yeah and it takes me wise
just I open up my heart and be like okay
what's you got yeah because you know
James has been James just been our Papa
Bear yeah yeah but Gary man described
that he is made over how many hundreds
of millions of dollars for this
franchise with his writing and he he
writes from a directorial stand what he
effortlessly
fill the position yeah yeah yeah yeah
and I I think it was a very similar
experience with with Michael shots who
were doing conjuring three with but
certainly with Gary who hadn't who had
you know is such a powerful writer and I
think that so so it worked to his favor
we knew he would understand the
structure and how these should be made
but certainly when you're playing
characters that you know we your
relationship to the camera and to the
director are very special right and an
actor you just want to feel comfortable
right if you're just so when you've got
when you're used to having that other
partner behind there and it's not no
matter how good the other person is it's
a little it just takes you a little bit
to go am i can i do my same it's very
true James would he was so specific he
would literally tell me what to do or
not to do with my my mouth
[Laughter]